Das immer wieder
Da sind wir wieder
Komplett Qualitätsoptionen haben haben jetzt Qualitätsoptionen
haben jetzt Qualitätsoptionen Qualitätsoptionen wieder nicht
Alter Twitch
Ihr habt auch keine Qualitätsoptionen. Ne ne ne ne es buggt wieder
Twitch
Give quality options. Ich muss doch Partner werden. Ich muss eigentlich ist das jetzt die optimale Gelegenheit mal wieder
Jetzt endlich mal meine Partner
Application oder wie man das nennt da auszufüllen da krieg ich immer Qualitätsoptionen
Ihr habt auch keine
Sagt
Easy
Easy easy easy
Ja 1080p oder automatisch
Soll ich es noch mal ausprobieren soll soll ich noch einmal neu starten und gucken ob jetzt Qualitäts Qualitätsoptionen kriegen oder soll ich so lassen
Könnt ihr euch aussuchen ich kanns noch mal ich kanns noch mal neu starten und hoffen dass wir jetzt Qualitätsoptionen kriegen
Lassen
Okay, wie gesagt für mich ist das ja kein problem ich habe damit keine schmerzen
Stabile 50. Übrigens Leute ich muss euch was zeigen ich muss euch was zeigen
Ich muss euch was zeigen
nicht mein nicht mein Unity Media Flame Video
Sondern ich habe mit dem Unity Media Support getweetet
Wie heißt die Unity Media Hilfe oder so muss ich euch mal zeigen
Unity Media Hilfe oder was Unity Media hilft
Aber mein also ich zeige euch das mal
Poggers also ich habe geschrieben
Vielleicht soll ich das ganze erst mal kurz auf Twitter posten
Die Musik laut stärke ok so bis sie laut oder
Aber so
Aber wobei ist es so in der Mitte das müsste eigentlich eigentlich müsste das ganz gut passen
So ich habe den Kran jetzt mal auf Twitter gepostet
Wir müssen jetzt mal kurz was testen wie flüssig das ganze ist
Meine ich muss mal meine Vorschau auch noch meine Vorschau ist flüssig passt das Video überhaupt 60 fps
Skammer anehe doch es ist wirklich 60 fps
Meine Vorschau ist jetzt nicht so wirklich super flüssig aber es geht
Ich dachte schon dass es gar maß das Video
Also ich wollte euch was zeigen und zwar gucken wir
Ich habe das ja das letzte mal erklärt dass ich oh nee jetzt ist das scheiß hier noch kaputt
Microsoft please
In der titel passt ja schon wieder und zwar ich habe ja aktuell upgrade gemacht auf das oktober update
Warum auch immer das oktober update heißt es ist eigentlich das december update aber Microsoft nennt das ganze das oktober update
Weil Microsoft der meinung ist weil Microsoft wahrscheinlich monat nicht richtig zählen kann das ursprünglich im oktober rausbringen wollte
Vor ich jetzt jetzt muss ich erstmal wo war ich vorher nicht dass ich das vergesse davor zu erzählen egal
Ja also ich ich habe geupgraded auf das oktober update und seitdem ist man startmenüs sind die sind die programme weg
Und ich habe festgestellt wenn ich die programme neu installiere oder update
Machen wir jetzt gerade mal dann sind sie wieder da
Logik verstehe ich nicht
Microsoft
Ich muss mal update ich muss mal programme updaten was updaten wir jetzt cmd blablabla also ich muss upgrade machen dass die programme wieder im startmenü da sind
muss man sich mal vorstellen dass es schon
richtig
hängen geblieben ist echt winnows in 2k 19 quasi lohnen sich
in 2k 19 quasi lohnen
Ja nachdem ich jetzt ich wollte euch nämlich in visual studio code eigentlich zeigen was ich das letzte mal aufgeschrieben habe zum internetanschluss
Was heck
Alter heck ist da los
Okay er hat trotzdem funktioniert
Ich habe das gefühl die haben den update zyklus von ubuntu abgeschaut ein bisschen bisschen die nennen ihre updates jetzt ja irgendwie mittlerweile auch nach
Monat und ja was ich was ich an sich gut finde ich finde das ubuntu update system ist eigentlich mit das beste
Ach mad du bist das gewesen
Du hast man powershell installation hier quasi gerade abgeschaltet
Verstehe
So hat er jetzt not warum haben wir überhaupt not installiert für was haben wir noch mal not installiert
Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr für irgendwas werden wir es wohl gebraucht haben
Habe ich den not installiert
Sagen gibt's vielleicht war das voraus dazu für postman das könnte natürlich sein
Die note wahrscheinlich für view nee wir machen ja noch nicht mal note mit also wir machen ja noch nicht mal view mit webpack und gedöns wir machen ja view ganz billig quasi mit include
So wenn das jetzt durch ist da kann ich euch zeigen was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte weil wenn aus der meinung ist mein startmenü darf nicht mehr funktionieren
Windows ja der Meinung ist, mein Startmenü darf nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ich hab's hier letztens auf Twitter auch geschrieben,
dass es mit so simplen Sachen überhaupt Probleme gibt.
Also das kann ja doch eigentlich keiner mehr erzählen, dass nach einem Windows Update das Startmenü nicht mehr geht.
Das ist doch eigentlich, dass so simple, essentielle Dinge schiefgehen können, das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
So, ist doch erstmal ein Update irgendwann nochmal fertig.
Ah, wir können wirklich den Studio Code schon aufmachen. Und zwar, wir hatten das letzte Mal uns doch hier gespeichert,
was ich mit meinem Internetanschluss machen könnte.
Und zwar, ich hatte ja zur Auswahl nochmal so Recap für alle, die sich mitgekriegt haben.
Aktuell ist es so, also aktueller Stand ist, ich habe einen Internetanschluss von der Telekom,
einen VDSL 100 mit 40 ab, 100 runter und Telefon.
Und ich habe einen Unity Media Internetanschluss mit 100 down, 6 ab, Fernsehgedöns.
Ja, genau, also so sieht das aktuell aus bei mir.
Und das ist, geh weg, und das ist einfach zu teuer.
Deswegen will ich einen von beiden wegschmeißen.
Die Kombination an sich habe ich nur aus dem einzigen Grund, weil ich mehr Upload wollte
und zum damaligen Zeitpunkt Unity Media leider nicht mehr Upload hatte.
Und deswegen habe ich gesagt, ok, ich mache bei der Telekom VDSL anstatt 16K, was ich am Anfang hatte.
So, das war der Hintergedanke.
Und jetzt gibt es die Möglichkeit bei der Telekom, dass sich 250, die haben ausgebaut bei uns,
also die haben jetzt quasi ihr VDSL Vectoring gedöns, haben sie noch dabei gemacht.
Ok, und jetzt kann ich bei der Telekom kriegen 250 down, 40 ab.
Da habe ich gesagt, an sich hätte ich aber am liebsten, am liebsten hätte ich die Telekom weg,
weil ich stream jetzt ja immer über die Telekom und wir haben, wie oft ist das Stream schon abgebrochen,
weil die Telekom mal wieder der Meinung war, DSL Modem verliert Sync oder Telekom hat scheiß Verbindungen.
Zu vielen CDNer, zu vielen so Contentgeschichten, zu YouTube hat ja die Telekom schon traditionell eine scheiß Verbindung.
Und YouTube, Telekom ist bei mir nicht sonderlich stabil und auch die Verbindung hin ist bei vielen Sachen scheiße.
Deswegen würde ich am liebsten die Telekom loswerden.
Das war Super Vectoring wahrscheinlich, also das, wo man 250 down kriegen kann.
Und deswegen wollte ich eigentlich, und das haben wir ja hier das letzte Mal aufgeschrieben,
deswegen wollte ich eigentlich komplett zu Unity Media wechseln, weil Unity Media hat jetzt einen neuen Tarif,
400 MBit down, 40 ab mit Power Upload und es ist sogar noch ein paar Euro billiger.
Wohlgemerkt, da kommt noch der Kabelanschluss für Fernsehen dabei, aber den, ja den bräuchte ich ja so oder so.
Moin, Ande, den bräuchte ich ja so und so.
Und das große Problem bei Unity Media war das hier.
Ich habe ja mit denen schon lange rumgezaggert bei meinem Unity Media Anschluss, dass ich wieder einen ordentlichen,
also ich hatte, ich hatte Probleme, ich habe es euch ja das letzte Mal gezeigt, ich hatte damals Probleme mit YouTube Upload,
das hat irgendwie 3000 Stunden gedauert, jetzt ohne Scheiß, das stand wirklich im Upload-Balken,
vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere noch drinnen.
Warum nicht Vordafone, Vordafone hat bei mir nichts eigenes, die haben bloß Resale-Gedöns.
Ja, jetzt habe ich zu viel Chat gekocht, wo bin ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben, ja.
Also und ich habe ja mit Unity Media lange hin und her gezackert, damals auch auf Twitter,
weil wie gesagt 3000 Minuten YouTube Uploads, dafür habe ich es mir damals nicht geholt, das war total affig.
Und, ja ja, Nilsson, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich will den Kabelanschluss hier haben für Fernsehzeug,
aber ich will keinen Triple Play mehr, weil die Zusatzfernsehdinger brauche ich nicht.
Ja und, warte mal, ich habe voll aus dem Takt gekommen.
Zumindest, ja genau, und dann habe ich dann irgendwann ordentlich IPv4 wieder gekriegt bei Unity Media und gut war.
Und das Problem ist jetzt bei der ganzen Geschichte, normalerweise hört man ja immer schlechte, schlechte News,
wenn man jetzt beispielsweise seinen Vertrag umstellen und upgraden, dass man dann auf einmal wieder Dual-Stack-Lite kriegt,
also diesen Kack hier und den wollte ich nicht.
Und ich habe mir ja auch überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einfach Unity Media Business holen soll,
mal davon abgesehen, dass es auch nicht so viel billiger ist als jetzt zwei Anschlüsse, aber die haben keinen Power-Upload,
da gibt es nur maximal 20 oder 25 MBit Upload, was irgendwie auch kacke ist, wenn die normale Variante für den 0815-Belutzer schon 40 hat,
warum Business-Leute nur 25 kriegen, man weiß es nicht.
So, und nun habe ich gedacht, fragst du doch mal die Unity Media Support auf Twitter,
und ich habe gesagt, bla, bla, bla, zwei Leitungen, Unity Media, Telekom hauptsächlich, Unity Media jetzt aktuell nur als Backup,
eine soll weg, mein Anschluss ist nicht mehr DS Lite, Problem mit IPv4, ja und VPN, das nicht nur YouTube damals,
VPN war ein Riesenproblem, VPN war echt ein Riesenproblem, ich hatte Probleme mich einmal von der Arbeit zu verbinden,
also von dort, sei es jetzt über das Handy, VPN oder sowas, Heim, wenn ich nachgucken wollte, was die Heimautomatisierung macht oder irgendwas, ging nicht richtig,
also besser gesagt ging gar nicht, weil wir da nur IPv4 haben, du kannst vergessen, du kommst halt nicht ordentlich von IPv4 auf IPv6,
und umgedreht ging es auch nicht, ich konnte, ich konnte quasi kaum mit diesem Getunnel von Unity Media, konnte ich quasi nicht per VPN von mir daheim auf die Arbeit,
das ist natürlich noch eine beschissenere Kombination, ja, weil das ist ja, das ist ja irgendwo notwendig gewesen, und da haben die das umgestellt,
so, und jetzt habe ich gefragt, kann ich IPv4 behalten, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel hier auf Fly 400 Upgrade,
und da hat der Unity Media Typ gesagt, da hat der Patrick erstmal ein bisschen rumgeflamed,
was sonst, so, und der sagt ja, du behältst IPv4 auch bei der Umstellung deines Vertrages,
jawoll, sehr nice, sehr nice, das ist schön, Nilsson, ich hätte auch am liebsten einen richtigen Dual Stack anstatt IPv4,
so einen ordentlichen Dual Stack anstatt IPv4, und da habe ich gesagt, okay, geht das auch, dass ich umsteige von 100 MBit Triple Play,
weil da ist so ein Zusatzfernsehgeschiss drin, was kein Mensch braucht, wollen wir wetten, der Support hat von IPv4, keine Ahnung,
der Support ist nicht schlecht, also die ganzen Social Media Supporte, sowohl von der Telekom als auch von der Bahn, als auch von Unity Media und sowas,
das ist eigentlich der beste Support, wo man sich bei den ganzen Läden hinwetten kann, jetzt ohne Scheiß, Leute,
wenn ihr wirklich mal mit Leuten reden wollt, wo dann auch welche da sitzen, die irgendwie ein bisschen Ahnung haben,
dann wendet euch an den Social Media Support von den ganzen Läden, das ist wirklich die beste Variante,
so, und da habe ich ihn gefragt, geht das denn jetzt, dass ich das alte 100 MBit Triple Play plus Kabelanschluss umstelle,
auf einen neuen 400 MBit Two Play mit Power Upload, Kabelanschluss, weil ich die Zusatz-TV-Angebote nicht haben will,
und dann sagt er, das können wir machen, bitte Kundentaten per TM, habe ich noch nicht, weil ich muss erstmal,
Big Brain, erstmal gucken, wie ich das genau mache vorher, weil ich muss Telekom noch kündigen,
und da muss ich ja irgendwie noch die Telefonnummer von der Telekom, bevor ich kündige, portieren,
und ich habe mir gedacht, nachdem es immer so ein Riesenakt ist mit Telefonnummern,
weil wir haben halt noch eine relativ gute Ortstelefonnummer, auch wenn ich persönlich damit nicht telefoniere,
meine Mutter telefoniert hier, alt Oldschool, ja, mit Telefon, und wir haben halt noch eine Ortsvorwahl,
und es kennen auch alle nur unsere Ortstelefonnummer, das heißt wir müssen irgendwie diese komische Telefonnummer behalten,
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, bevor ich die Telefonnummer jetzt zu Unity Media portiere,
und es wieder an die Leute vor unlösbare Aufgaben stellt, portiere ich die Telefonnummer von der Telekom
einfach zu einem VoIP-Anbieter für 2,50€ im Monat, und mache da drüber mein Telefonzeug,
und kündige die Telekom komplett, alles weg, komplett weg Telekom, brauche ich da immer,
und das war dann die optimale Kombination, da hätte ich nämlich das hier,
so ungefähr für, sogar nochmal, sogar nochmal für, sogar nochmal 10€ billiger, das ist der Witz,
habe ich nämlich bei Unity Media im Kundencenter gelesen, die wollen diese alten Verträge nicht mehr haben,
die wollen diese alten 100 MB Tripleplay-Dinger nicht mehr haben, die bieten einem an jetzt quasi für 10€ weniger im Monat,
als es normalerweise kostet, umzusteigen, das heißt, das hier würde sogar nur 43€ kosten,
ich vermute mal nur die ersten 12 Monate oder so, ja, irgendwie sowas, müssen wir mal genauer gucken,
und da drauf kommt natürlich nochmals 20€ für den Kabelanschluss, und da bin ich bei 63€,
und das ist ungefähr, ungefähr, so über den Daumen gepeilt, die Hälfte von dem, was ich jetzt im Monat bezahle,
und ich habe einen schnelleren Internetanschluss und alles, und in einem Jahr oder so, wenn ich dann mir was anderes überlegt habe,
kann man vielleicht den Kabelanschluss auch abbestellen, weil der ist dafür nicht erforderlich, das ist nämlich auch gut im Vergleich zur Tripleplay.
Ne, danach ist, danach sind glaube ich die 53€, also im ersten Jahr kostet es, glaube ich, nur 39€, stimmt, danach wird es 53€,
so, also dann bezahle ich im Endeffekt halt hier 73€ im Monat für Internet, Telefon, nein, ja gut, ne, 45€,
weil es kommt ja auch ein 2€ VoIP-Anbieter drauf, dann bezahle ich quasi 75€ im Monat für Internet, Telefon, Fernseher,
also es ist okay, ja, und ich habe mir auch mal, ich habe ein bisschen mit Dings hier rum gebastelt,
mit denen hier, das ist ja auch so ein, so ein Fernseher, Fernseher, wie nennt man das, Watt,
ne, das ist kein Video- und Demand-Dienst, wie heißt das, ja, Fernseher, TV-Streaming-Dienst,
der ja mittlerweile in Deutschland, habe ich gesehen, auch die privaten, bis auf RTL, in HD-Auflösung hat,
und das Geile ist, was ich gefunden habe, das ist nämlich auch nochmal eine Option,
es gibt nen, ja, ich promise es, ich hab noch den richtigen IPv4,
so, und ich hab nämlich nen Script gefunden, auf GitHub, für Satu, wie man den genau ausspricht,
wo man quasi mit nem Satu-Premium-Abo die ganzen Geschichten in TV-Hatend rein kriegt,
und das Ding verwende ich ja aktuell eh schon als TV, so aber halt mit, mit, mit Unity Media, mit Kabel, mit DVBC-Karte drin,
und das wär natürlich nochmal cooler, weil, da könnte man sich auf lange Sicht,
die 20 Euro für den Kabelanschluss sparen, und bräuchte nur 10 Euro für das Premium-Abo,
also ihr seht ja, ich hab, ich hab ein bisschen gerechnet, und da sind die privaten in HD mit drinne,
bis auf RTL, was bei anderen nicht drinne gibt,
bei dir ist RTL auch in HD drinne, ne, das kann eigentlich nicht sein,
achso, ja, aber du kommst nicht aus Deutschland, oder?
ne, guck, weil in Premium haben die den nicht, warte mal, oder doch?
oder doch? ach, dann ist das mittlerweile drinne,
ok, ja auch gut, hab ich auch keine Schmerzen mit,
wie wärs mit einer Satzschuss, ja, das ist die nächste Option, das könnte man auch machen,
warum will man eigentlich RTL schauen, keine Ahnung,
ich bin in dem Fall nur Ausführender, ich guck ja gar kein Fernsehen,
ja, aber so machen wir das, so in der Richtung werden wir das machen,
na, wie ihr es jetzt übersagt, weil ihr, der Chat macht ja nicht mit bei meiner Internet-Auswahl,
aber darauf wirds wahrscheinlich rauslaufen,
und wenn ich 400, 400 MBit down habe,
ja, da ist auch mal irgendwie 2, 5, 6 MBit HD Fernsehstreams ohne Probleme drinne,
das juckt das ja mal mal 400 MBit down mal absolut gar nicht,
gut, dann kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen, was ich heute machen will,
und zwar, ich zeig's euch mal, für die Leute, die den Anfang nicht mitgekriegt haben davon,
wo ist es denn hier, Progas ist es,
hast du die Sync-Abrüche mal prüfen lassen, ja, ich hab mal mit dem, sie haben gemessen,
das ist so die Standard-Antwort immer, so nach dem Motto, ja, hier irgendwie, Sync verliert immer,
haben sie gesagt, wir haben ihre Leitung gemessen und jetzt ist alles wieder gut,
das ist aber nicht, lohnt.
Es war mal eine Zeit lang noch schlimmer,
und ich hab in der Fritzbox den Grams schon runtergestellt auf quasi stabile Verbindung über Qualität oder sowas,
was auch diese Option überhaupt macht,
so, also für alle, die es noch nicht kennen,
ich zeig das mal kurz,
und zwar,
wir haben in den letzten zwei Streams für Hardware-Rad ein Tool gebastelt,
mit dem sie ihre Windows-Rechner aktivieren können,
ich zeig das mal,
auf Windows,
auf Windows-Keys liegt,
gebated,
massive-gebated,
hat mir eh keiner geklaut,
ist das andere Tool jetzt auch abgekackt,
hab ich das jetzt, Moment,
Moment, ich glaub, ich hab das andere auch irgendwie kaputt gemacht,
ne, geht doch, was auch immer,
was auch immer, ja, also ich hab ja hier so ein Tool gebastelt,
wo sie ihre Keys verwalten können, übrigens das sind, also für alle, die jetzt wirklich irgendwie gedacht haben,
das sind, das sehen zwar aus wie Windows-Keys,
das sind die Keys, die Microsoft offiziell bei ihrer Seite stehen hat, wenn es um KMS-Test-Keys geht,
das ist nichts tolles drin, plus ein paar sind auch ungültig, weil ich ja Einser dazwischen geschrieben hab,
so und wer das Tool das letzte Mal gesehen hat, weiß, das ist, war ein bisschen simpler damals,
und ich hab's jetzt noch ein bisschen erweitert, man kann jetzt quasi einen Kommentar einfügen,
wenn man Keys hinzufügt,
so ein bisschen größer, wenn man, man kann den Kram bearbeiten,
da geht so, das ist richtig fancy, oder guckt euch das mal an,
BÄM,
ha, ist das nicht geil,
guck hier,
BÄM,
geht das Fenster auf,
jaja,
das ist richtig, ja,
Poke-Jump,
easy,
proger,
so,
ja, und da kann man jetzt hier hinzufügen, quasi einen Kommentar,
kann man hier sowas, also, das sollte nicht für Kappa HD Omega 00 frische Keys verwenden,
sondern, da kann man sowas reinschreiben, wie Key-Lieferung vom 1.12.2018,
zum Beispiel, so ein bisschen seriöse Geschichte,
und wenn du dann da draufklickst, kriegst du halt alle Keys,
die du, guckt euch mal an, wie schön sticky das ist, seht ihr das hier oben,
sticky,
wenn man scrollt, die Tabelle bleibt oben,
ist nice, oder,
finde ich das nicht auch nice,
guckt man scrollt, und zack, die Tabelle bleibt oben,
ha,
krasser Shit,
richtig, richtig klebrig sind wir auch, ja,
ja, und wenn man dann hier, kann man die unterschiedlichen Key-Lieferungen durchklicken,
und die geht immer auf, die sehen jetzt bloß gleich aus,
die sind nicht gleich, ich hab halt immer die gleichen Keys wieder kopiert,
also, wieder die gleichen Keys, mit leichten Änderungen drinnen,
mit was wurde das Framework designt, also, was, nein, mit,
mit was wurde das Interface designt, also,
ja, was, da ist Vue.js drunter,
wobei die Optik ist, mit keinem zählt, das ist einfach,
so wie es meinem Hirn entsprungen ist,
dementsprechend sieht das TSS auch nicht allzu schicke aus,
ja, und ich zeige euch nochmal was,
ich zeige nochmal was, was auch richtig nice ist,
so, ähm,
wollte ich jetzt sagen,
spricht was gegen eine Prise Bootstrap, ja, weil ich,
benutze das ja hauptsächlich dazu, dass ich erstens was,
programmiertechnisch zu streamen hab,
und zweitens, dass ich selbst ein bisschen was lerne,
und wenn ich ein fertiges Bootstrap, ähm,
machen würde, dann würde ich da nichts bei lernen, ja,
ach ja, was richtig nice ist, was ich euch noch zeigen wollte,
und zwar, ähm, also mal angenommen, man sagt jetzt hier,
neue Key-Lieferung hinzufügen,
dann können wir jetzt sagen, hier, was weiß ich,
neue Keys, ähm, 4.12.19 Uhr,
so, das erste, wenn da nichts drinne steht,
und ich sag jetzt absenden, dann macht er,
Bam, Kommentar darf nicht leer sein, Fehlermeldung,
Server-Side, ja, Bam, Kommentar darf nicht leer sein,
sagt er jetzt, so, und dann werden wir jetzt einen Kommentar reinschreiben,
und versuchen die Keys zu pasten, und sagt er,
die können nicht leer sein,
ja, und, äh, noch viel geiler, wenn ich da jetzt reinschreibe,
Lul, alter Lan, oder sowas, dann sagt er,
ah, Key not valid,
ah, ah,
das ist schon sehr nice, oder, muss man mal sagen,
das ist schon sehr nice,
so, und wenn man da jetzt was ordentliches reinschreibt,
sowas wie hier, also ich mein, ob das wirklich ein gültiger Windows-Key ist,
kann er ja nicht ausprobieren, er muss halt auf den Regex matchen,
aber wenn wir jetzt hier sowas hier machen,
das ist, das ist ein gültiger Windows-Key, zumindest vom Format her, ja,
ähm, zack, Bam, da ist er, neue Keys,
es ist sortiert nach dem neuesten,
also, es ist gruppiert nach dem, nach dem, äh, ja, halt,
nach der Lieferung, nein, das war halt nach dem Kommentar,
und, äh, insgesamt nach Datum, das heißt,
die neuesten sind immer zuerst, und ich habe Coggers mittlerweile auch geändert,
Coggers ist der Kommando-Zeichen klein, den man
auf die Rechner zieht, um es dann letztendlich,
einen Duplettenfilter wäre auch nice, ich
hab, glaub ich, sogar einen,
probieren wir das doch mal aus, probieren wir das doch mal aus,
ähm, ich glaube, ich hab nen Filter, dass das doppelte Keys nicht gehen,
aber ich glaub, der wirft noch keine Fehlermeldung, warte mal,
wir probieren das jetzt mal einzufügen, ja, macht er nicht,
aber er wirft keine Fehlermeldung, das können wir noch machen,
wenn ein doppelter Key drin ist, guck, er macht's nicht,
sonst wird jetzt hier ein neuer Key kommen,
ähm, also ich filtre doppelte Keys schon raus, aber,
ähm, der wirft noch keine Fehlermeldung,
ja, aber findet ihr's nicht nice, ihr guckt mal hier,
wie das wackelt, und dann, es faded aus nach vier Sekunden,
seht ihr, guckt ihr so, wackelt, wackelt,
hallo, Kommentar darf nicht leer sein, und letztlich gleich,
krass, oder?
ja,
ja, hier oben fügt man neue Keys hinzu,
und hier editiert man halt die alten,
ach ja, und übrigens, das löschen funktioniert jetzt auch,
wenn ich jetzt sagen will, ich will neue Keys löschen,
sag ich einfach zack, und dann kommt noch mal ne Abfrage,
blablabla, einer löschen, ok, blablabla, weg, weg ist er,
sehr nice, ne, sehr, sehr nice,
ah, da hat er auch noch, ja, das stimmt noch,
aber wer auch immer das geschrieben hat, hat recht,
die wollten noch nen Filter einbauen,
dass doppelte Keys nicht, äh, nicht eingelegt werden können,
beziehungsweise auch übergreifend, und vor allem,
dass ne ordentliche Fehlermeldung kommt,
den Modal könnte man noch schöner machen, meinst du den hier,
oder meinst du den hier?
weißt du, meinst du das Popup?
den Alert, das ist so ganz normale Browser,
äh, Alert Box, kann man die stylen?
ne, die kann man nicht stylen, oder?
den Alert kann man nicht stylen,
das ist halt von,
halt da, der Chrome Alert ist das,
so, ähm, da, das ist das Tool,
zwar man sieht da so Dinger wie, ähm,
hier jetzt bei mir nicht so viel drinnen, weil das nur die Testrechner sind,
man sieht hier beispielsweise drinnen, also in der Übersicht
sieht man nur die Keys, die noch quasi, äh, unbenutzt sind,
hier hat man unter Logs, hat man da ne History stehen,
welchen, welchen Rechner man aktiviert hat, mit, ähm,
also welchen Rechner man aktiviert hat mit, ähm,
also welchen Rechner mit welcher Mac man wann aktiviert hat,
da steht, ich hab gestern die, die, die, ähm,
Windows Key Datenbank von, von den Jungs gesehen,
und da ist natürlich mehr, mehr unter Logs aktivierte Rechner drinnen,
wie, wie Keys, ja, ähm,
ja und bei Stats sieht man ein bisschen Zeug wie aktivierte Rechner heute und so,
das ist noch relativ rudimentär, da ist jetzt noch nichts großartig drinnen,
ist das auch SQL Injection sicher?
Ich denk mal, allzu viel Injection kannst du da nicht,
so, äh, vorausgesetzt, äh, EF Core
spackt nicht rum.
Dann war ich mir da relativ wenig Gedanken, da sind, sind keine,
keine selbst zusammengebauten SQL-Dinger drinnen im, im laufenden Betrieb.
So.
Ja, okay, und jetzt machen wir weiter,
und zwar eine Sache, die wir noch einbauen müssen,
ist, ähm, es ist mir nämlich aufgefallen,
dass es noch sehr praktisch wäre,
ist, ähm, es ist mir nämlich aufgefallen, dass es noch sehr praktisch wäre,
wenn dieses Tool, also das funktioniert ja folgendermaßen,
es gibt ja noch einen Kommando-Zeilen-Client dafür,
nämlich Proggers ist hier der Server mit den, mit den Keys drinnen,
und Coggers,
beste Programmler aller Zeiten, ey.
So, und, und, und,
Coggers, ähm,
macht so Dinger wie,
oh, hier hab ich schon angefangen, versucht ein bisschen Zeug mit Formatieren zu machen,
ne, ne, ne, ne, das kommt weg, das brauchen wir nicht,
geh weg, geh weg,
da, der Nightbot geht ab,
so, ähm,
und das hier ist das, äh, kleinen Programm,
das kommt quasi auf die Systeme drauf, die installiert werden,
und, ähm,
der aktiviert Windows,
der aktiviert ist übrigens auch nur ein Test-Key, also müssen wir gar nicht probieren,
der aktiviert Windows, im Hintergrund,
also, der macht ein paar Fenster auf und aktiviert Windows dann,
und das funktioniert relativ zuverlässig,
da gibt es eigentlich keine Probleme, und jetzt, ähm,
haben sie sich gedacht, es wäre noch ganz nice,
wenn das Programm auch Festplatten formatieren könnte,
ja, und, ähm,
der Floji Baited,
der Floji Baited, das ist ein,
das ist ein Windows KMS-Key,
das ist ein Windows KMS-Key, da funktioniert nicht,
also, lasst euch nicht gebaten,
ok, ähm, so, und jetzt,
versuchen wir mal einzubauen,
dass man damit auch Festplatten,
wie kann man Seite vor SQL-Injection schützen,
das einfachste ist, keine eigenen SQL-Queries basteln,
und wenn man eigene SQL-Queries bastelt, dann, oh, wie hieß der Kram,
ich hab schon das Problem, dass mir den Namen, den Namen von manchen Dingern nicht einfallen,
obwohl man es eigentlich normalerweise verwendet, äh, Parameters, ähm,
also sprich,
Beispiel, ja, ähm, wenn du keine SQL,
Prepared Statements, Prepared Statements heißt es, glaube ich, ja,
ich glaub, so hieß der Kram,
ja, also, du hast, du hast die Möglichkeit, ne,
so, die Billigvariante ist sowas hier,
SQL, dann sagst du sowas wie hier,
Select Coggers from Poggers,
oder was hier sowas ist, Select, äh, Top, äh, irgendwas,
also, so, das wäre, oder, sagen wir mal,
rare,
rare, blub, äh, gleich eins,
oder, ne, wie, wie geht das in SQL, einfach nur so, gell,
so, das wär, das wär so die Billigvariante von, ähm,
also, sagen wir mal so, das, das hier ist UserInput,
UserInput ist in dem Fall eins, so,
und die Billigvariante SQL,
wo man auf jeden Fall Probleme kriegt, wär das hier,
na, das ist klar, im Endeffekt, ich krieg nen, nen, nen,
nen Input vom User, ist egal, wie ich den krieg, ob ich den jetzt, ähm,
übers Terminal krieg, als Post, irgendwie als Request vom Web oder so, ist egal,
ähm, wenn ich sowas hier bastel,
dann sind Probleme vorprogrammiert, also, das wird auf gar keinen Fall machen,
weil, du kannst jetzt hier,
anstatt eins, kannst du ja auch sowas hier übers, äh, übergeben,
so,
und, ähm, wenn du, wenn du jetzt das hier übergibst,
und es einfach nur hinten dran hängst, dann wird zuerst ausgeführt,
ähm, select Coggers from Poggers, ich kann mal Zeug nicht vorlesen,
das klingt schon übelst behindert, äh,
select Sternchen Coggers from Poggers,
select Sternchen Coggers from Poggers, wir haben plupp gleich,
so, User Input, eins, ist ein gültiges Statement,
ähm, und danach führt er allerdings noch Drop Table Bashen, Alter, aus,
das ist schlecht, das ist ganz schlecht, so macht man das nicht,
so, ähm, die nächste Variante ist, man verwendet, ähm,
ich sag mal so ein bisschen,
leiteres, ähm,
SQL Mapper, SQL Framework, da kann man dann sowas hier in der Richtung machen,
ich mach das jetzt nur mal sinnbildlich, weil ich, äh,
äh, ich weiß, wie ich überhaupt mit EF Core das machen würde,
also, mal angenommen, du hast,
achso, ja, äh,
die, früher hat man das so gemacht, dann hatte man so eine Funktion,
so nach dem Motto, äh, äh, irgendwie, irgendwie,
ich kann das gar nicht schreiben,
äh, User Input, und dann hast du das hier irgendwie reingepiped,
da hat er geguckt, ob da nicht verbotene Zeichen drin sind und sowas,
viel zu kompliziert, die meisten, äh,
SQL Frameworks, äh, Mapper und sonst was,
bieten sowas hier an, dass du sagen kannst, hier sowas, was ist SQL Execute,
und dann sagst du, ähm,
so, ungefähr, ja, es ist immer von Framework zu Framework unterschiedlich,
User Input, dann würdest du das nämlich so machen,
und das sorgt, das setzt quasi den ersten Parameter an dieser Stelle ein,
sorgt allerdings dafür, dass, äh, jegliche, wenn es gescheit gemacht ist,
jegliche, ähm, User Inputs und sowas, dass das alles gereinigt wird und kein Scheiß ausgeführt wird,
so, und noch, noch schöner ist es eigentlich, wenn du einen kompletten, ähm,
Datenbank-Mapper verwendest, da machst du nämlich einfach nur noch sowas hier,
äh, wo sind, wo sind meine Controller?
Ja, da machst du nämlich nur noch sowas hier, da hast du einen Datenbank-Kontext,
wo du sagst, ähm,
keine Ahnung, ich will, äh, in die Datenbanken will ich eine Collection von Windows-Lizenzen drinne haben,
und dann kannst du noch ein paar Zeug, aber im Prinzip egal, du schreibst kein SQL mal von Hand,
das generiert quasi, in dem Fall ist es EF Core, Entity Framework Core, alles für dich,
und dann sagst du in deinem Controller am Ende,
plus noch sowas hier, ähm,
ja, sowas irgendwie, äh, Context, Get Unused License, Order, Buy, blablabla,
das ist im Prinzip auch irgendwo SQL, du kannst ja auch sagen sowas wie,
äh, irgendwas, bloß, dass du halt überhaupt kein SQL-Text mehr selbst zusammenbaust,
sondern, ähm,
ja,
da kann ja überhaupt nichts mehr passieren.
Schon RIP von Tumblr gehört?
Nee, habe ich nicht, aber ist Tumblr nicht das, was Yahoo irgendwann mal übernommen hat?
Ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo Yahoo was übernimmt, ist einem eigentlich klar, ähm,
äh, dass es nichts wird.
Okay, so, jetzt kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen, was wir heute machen,
das habe ich ja hier ein bisschen drumherum geschmetzt, wenn der Tag lang ist,
heute formatieren wir Festplatten mit C-Sharp.
Und ich habe mir im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen angeguckt, wie das Ganze funktioniert,
und wir müssen das natürlich in einer VM machen.
Ach ja, noch eine andere Sache, habt ihr gehört, dass, ähm,
auf VM was starten, habt ihr gehört, dass Microsoft angeblich, weil es gerade an einem Chat schreibt,
dass Microsoft angeblich an einem neuen Edge Browser arbeitet,
der nicht mehr Edge ist, sondern Chrome.
Edge ist anscheinend Geschichte,
wenn man den Gerüchten glaubt, ja.
So, also wir müssen dann unsere Windows VM jetzt erstmal,
ach ja, übrigens, ich, das mit dem Festplatten formatieren,
machen wir selbstverständlich in einer VM, weil ich keinen Bock habe,
meine, meinen Rechner irgendwie zu formatieren oder zu löschen oder sowas.
So, wir hängen mal testweise eine Platte dran.
Warum habe ich die eigentlich gelöscht? Ich hatte doch schon eine dran.
Naja, egal. Ähm,
ich habe nämlich zum Test schon eine dran gehängt, jetzt habe ich sie weggemacht, aber auch okay.
Ähm, hängen wir eine neue Platte dran, New Disk, Single File,
Disk irgendwie, keine Ahnung, also 8GB,
blah, vierte Platte, zack, einschalten.
Ähm, ja, es ist an sich, ist die Idee nicht schlecht.
Also, es ist gar nicht mal so unlogisch aus Microsoft, sich das zu tun,
weil keine Sau, wenn man mal ehrlich ist,
testet seine Anwendung und seine Webseiten auf Edge.
Oder kennt, kennt ihr irgendjemand, der seine Sachen auf Edge testet?
Also ich nicht, ich kenne keine, der Edge ausprobiert.
Ernsthaft? Okay, da habe ich nichts gesagt, aber,
sag mal, die meisten, die meisten testen es nicht auf Edge.
So, und Microsoft hat jetzt ja vor, dass man quasi Web-Anwendungen in den Windows-Store
irgendwie direkt pfeffern kann.
Und dementsprechend sollte der Kram natürlich auch ordentlich funktionieren,
und im Detail funktionieren Chrome und Edge halt nicht gleich.
Deswegen ist die Idee gar nicht so schlecht.
Mal eine Frage, wo du bei deinen Mainboards immer den optischen Sound ausganglängst,
was ist der Vorteil davon über Klinke, dass du es nicht konvertieren musst?
Also wenn du einen Klinken-Ausgang hast, dann muss ja erstmal dein digitales Audio
in analoges Audio, also halt in Stromschwankungen
und Wellen und Gedöns in analoges Signal konvertiert werden
und geht dann zu entweder den Lautsprechern direkt oder
zu irgendeinem Receiver oder sonst was, wo es dann wieder umgewandelt wird.
Im optischen Ausgang ist halt das Schöne, du schließt es einfach an und es wird
erst an der Stelle umgewandelt, wo dann auch es ausgegeben werden soll.
Ansonsten, ob du es wirklich hörst,
bei so Standard wage ich zu bezweifeln, ja.
So, und ich habe schon mal
auf die VM in Virtual Studio installiert,
wo wir das jetzt mit dem Festplattenformat ausprobieren können.
Nein, nein, das wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall machen.
Also wir sehen es, wir haben eine neue Festplatte drin, 8GB,
nicht initialisiert, nichts und fertig.
Die sollten mal lieber den EE killen statt den Edge, den EE können sie nicht killen,
also die haben ihn ja schon gekillt, soweit irgendwie möglich,
allerdings den EE selbst müssen sie drin lassen.
Sie machen ja am EE auch nichts, allerdings es gibt so viele
Anwendungen, die
in irgendwelchen Unternehmen eingesetzt werden, die einfach EE brauchen.
Bitte Antwort auf was denn?
Was, gibt es eine Möglichkeit,
was ist denn das für eine Frage WhiteLine58, gibt es eine Möglichkeit,
den Schulserver zu hacken, ist wichtig für meine Arbeit?
Wahrscheinlich gibt es die, ja, aber die Informationen sind halt absolut
nicht ausreichend.
Den Schulserver, das ist so absolut nichts sagend, das ist wie wenn ich sage,
kann ich in dem Online-Spiel cheaten? Wahrscheinlich kannst du es.
Ob es fertige Cheats dafür gibt, ist die Frage. Wenn es ein verbreitetes Spiel ist,
wahrscheinlich, wenn es nicht so verbreitet ist, vielleicht nicht, wenn es
noch schwieriger ist, das ist viel zu breit gefragt.
Aber nachdem die meisten
Sachen, die in der Schule betrieben werden,
meistens von Noobs betrieben werden, also sprich entweder von Lehrern, die das in
ihrer Freizeit machen oder teilweise sogar von irgendwelchen Schülern,
dann muss man wahrscheinlich gar nicht
mal großartig hacken und irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken finden, ausnutzen,
sondern man kommt wahrscheinlich schon relativ einfach drauf,
indem man einfach Passwörter ausprobiert.
Hey Max, war mal dir die Berufsschule auch so sinnlos? Bin zum Glück bald fertig.
Ja, die war bei mir auch extrem sinnlos. Also zum Thema Formatieren von Festplatten
unter Windows. Ich habe mich da
im Vorfeld ein bisschen schlau gemacht und zwar, es gibt wohl mehrere
Möglichkeiten, wie man eine Festplatte
unter Windows formatiert,
wie man quasi aus dem C-Sharp-Programm
eine Festplatte unter Windows formatiert. Die einfachste
Variante ist, man würde zum Beispiel
irgendwie einen Prozess starten und einfach
irgendwie einen Diskpart oder so mit Parametern aufrufen.
Das würde funktionieren. Die Sache ist
nicht schön, da man immer relativ schwierig
quasi mitbekommt, was denn ein externes
Programm, was man startet, eigentlich genau macht bzw. ob es Fehlermeldungen
gegeben hat, was der aktuelle Status ist und sonst was. Also quasi so ein Exakt
im Hintergrund ist immer so ein bisschen unschön. Wenn es nicht anders geht, okay.
Also das wäre die erste Variante.
Man würde einfach irgendwie in so ein paar CMD-Befehle
starten und dann hoffen, dass er auch alle Festplatten formatiert.
Die nächste Variante, die es gibt, ist
PowerShell. In PowerShell geht das auch.
PowerShell kann man sowas machen wie... Leute, ich muss mir erstmal
Chrome installieren. Ich muss mir erstmal in der VM Chrome installieren,
sonst geht es nämlich nicht, das funktioniert das nicht. Nein, wir wollen Google
nicht unterstützen.
Das nächste, was ich gefunden habe, ist
PowerShell Format Disk Windows.
Und man kann mit PowerShell sowas hier machen wie
Get Disks, wenn man das richtig schreiben könnte, dann kann man das auch machen.
Get Disks, nee, der Disk...
Ja, da kriegt man hier zum Beispiel schonmal welche
Platten angeschlossen sind, ob sie formatiert sind oder nicht.
Und da gab es, da habe ich irgendwo einen Beitrag gefunden,
wie man das macht. Das heißt, die zweite Variante, allerdings
leider nur minimal schönere Variante zum Festplatten formatieren,
wäre, ähm, quasi anstatt Disk Part
mit Parametern aufzurufen, einfach ein kurzes
PowerShell Skript aufrufen, was das für uns macht.
Das ist natürlich auch unschön, weil ich kriege überhaupt nicht richtig mit,
an welchen Stellen da was schiefgeht. Das nächste ist, man könnte PowerShell
in dem C-Sharp-Programm hosten und dort quasi schrittweise
die Dinger machen, das ist aber auch nicht sonderlich schön.
Die nächste Variante, wie wir Festplatte formatieren können, wäre mit
GUI-Automatisierung, das machen wir aber nicht, sage ich gleich dazu,
also sprich, dass man Klicks simulieren würde, so Klicks, die das hier machen
im Endeffekt, ja, äh, initialisieren, hinzufügen, bla,
das können wir aber gleich verwerfen, GUI-Automatisierung ist komplett von Arsch.
Da ist das Fenster mal ein bisschen weiter links und es funktioniert nicht mehr.
Das ist Mist. So, und jetzt war ich so ein bisschen
mit meinem Datein am Ende, weil alles, was ich sonst so gefunden habe,
war, also wie man quasi Festplatten formatiert, aus dem
Prinzip, ist egal, ob es ein.NET-Programm ist oder sowas,
oh, ich hab eine Donation gekriegt, ich hab meine, muss ich mal aufmachen,
ich hab meine Anzeige gar nicht da, wartet mal.
Ich hab das schon mal, danke für die Donation, aber ich muss mal nachgucken.
Von Hardware hat 5 Euro. Kannst du bei dem Programm noch
einfügen, dass der PC sich selbstständig zum Kunden verschickt?
Wenn du mir, wenn DHL sowas anbietet,
wenn DHL eine Abholbeauftragung,
ich weiß, dass du das eigentlich nicht ernst weißt, aber nur
von der Idee her, wenn DHL eine
Abholbeauftragungs-API anbietet, könnte man das theoretisch sogar
machen, aber da muss man halt wirklich gucken,
dass es richtig funktioniert, sonst beauftragt man DHL 50 mal was abzuholen,
ohne dass sowas da ist. Ist vielleicht keine allzu clevere Idee.
So,
ja, und jetzt war ich, wie gesagt, ein bisschen mit meinem Latein am Ende.
Übrigens, wenn ich was übersehe, müsstest du das einfach nochmal schreiben.
Ich kann grad nicht denken und Progress machen.
Und jetzt war ich, wie gesagt, ein bisschen mit meinem Latein am Ende, wie wir das am Ende
angeschrieben haben. Und jetzt bin ich wieder
mit meinem Latein am Ende.
Und jetzt war ich, wie gesagt, ein bisschen mit meinem Latein am Ende, wie wir das am schönsten machen.
Und da hab ich halt mal ein bisschen weiter gesucht, so wie könnte man
Beispiel, da hab ich mir Stack Overflow, so nach dem Motto Format,
C-Sharp, Disk hab ich das so ganz billig gesucht.
Und dann findest du dann irgendwie Formatting USB Drive, Formatting It's Drive.
Und dann hab ich irgendwann das hier gefunden.
Und da ging's schon Richtung schwarze Magie
Winner von Windows, wo ich dann gesehen hab, aha, du machst
hier irgendwie so nen WMI-Objekt-Such,
so nen Win32-Volume-Format. Da bin ich allerdings
auch nicht weitergekommen, weil ich festgestellt hab, okay,
ich kann ja ne Sache nur formatieren, die schon partitioniert ist, die schon da ist.
Was wir ja nicht haben, wir haben ja ne komplett
uninitialisierte, ne Disk ohne
irgendwie Partition drauf, ohne MBR, ohne GPT, ohne
alles, gar nix. Und die nächste Sache,
die ich gefunden hab, ich muss euch das jetzt nochmal zeigen, dass man mal sieht, wie absolut für ein Arsch das wieder unter
Windows ist. Die nächste Sache, die ich gefunden habe,
nannte sich, ähm,
ah, warte mal, wie hieß das?
Wie hieß das? Das war ganz, ganz
mir, ähm,
hier genau, C-Sharp,
Win32-Disk.
So, und das war ganz, ganz
merkwürdig.
Da musstest du dann
ganz merkwürdige Kernel-Aufrufe oder sowas machen, ne, das war jetzt Linux.
Ähm,
ja, das war das hier, glaube ich,
oder? Ganz, ganz, ganz furchtbar abgedrehtes
Zeug, wo ich, das was ich sogar ausprobiert hab, was ich versucht hab
nachzubauen, was auch ein bisschen funktioniert hat, aber es wirklich so
abgrundtief hässlich war, dass ich mir gedacht hab,
das machen wir nicht. Also ich finde, ich finde jetzt
die, ich finde jetzt den eigentlichen Artikel
nicht, den ich, den ich gefunden hab,
aber es war wirklich ganz, ganz grausam. Das waren irgendwie 300-Zeilen, äh,
Code mit irgendwelchem uralt Windows-Zeug, ganz, ganz
richtig eklig.
Was ist das hier? Ich muss, ich muss euch mal den Source-Code zeigen, das war so,
so eklig.
Ich find's jetzt leider nicht mehr, aber das war wirklich
Disk-Management-Control, oh ja, das war's.
So, so grausam, äh.
Ja.
Nee. Den Artikel hatte ich auch.
Und es war so eklig, dass ich mir gedacht hab, nee, das mach ich nicht, da rufe ich lieber PowerShell auf.
Ja, hier, genau. Das, das, das
ist es. Da jede Menge Native-Sachen, die du aufrufen musst, und das ist
nur der Teil fürs Disk-Initialisen, ja.
Da ist noch kein Partitionieren und kein Formatieren dabei und auch kein Laufwerksbuchstaben-Mapping.
Also, ihr könnt euch vorstellen, dieses, dieses
Geschwubbel von Windows-RP-Calls mal 5. Und dann
hätte man die Sache ungefähr formatiert. Ganz, ganz eklig.
Und dann hab ich irgendwann was gefunden, das nennt sich, ähm,
Windows-Storage-Service oder irgendwie sowas.
Und da sieht man mal schon wieder, wie viel Scheiße Microsoft mittlerweile für den gleichen
Krempel hat. Ähm, und das, das Ding hieß irgendwie dann,
ähm, muss ich mal nachgucken, warte mal, das hab ich mir irgendwie aufgeschrieben.
Das hieß
Windows-Storage-Service-Management.
Hier, MSFT heißt das.
MSFT. Und das sind die, ähm,
Ähm,
das ist nicht die, ja, mag die Abkürzung für Microsoft sein, aber
das da mein ich. So, dann hab ich das hier gefunden.
Das ist anscheinend relativ neu, seit Windows 2012 oder so.
Und das ist die Windows-Storage-Management-RP.
Also quasi gefühlt die siebte Variante, die wir jetzt
gefunden haben, wie man unter Windows Festplatten formatieren kann.
Und das ist das erste, wo ich sagen würde, ja,
das ist halbwegs benutzbar.
Und ich hab damit schon ein bisschen rumgespielt und damit probieren wir heute mal, ob wir es schaffen, die Festplatte zu formatieren.
Wie gesagt, das ist ein bisschen langsamer, das Windows Studio hier, einfach aus dem Grund,
weil ich innerhalb von einer, von einer, äh, VM bin.
Moin, oh Nilesi.
So, und ich würd sagen, wir fangen jetzt mal an. Wir machen jetzt irgendwie mal eine, äh, Public
Glass Disk Formatter. Könnte sein, dass wir das Ding gleich
noch umbenennen. So, und ich hab mir natürlich auch schon ein paar Beispiele
rausgesucht im Vorfeld, wo ich rumgebastelt hab. Das heißt, ich muss das jetzt nicht alles
komplett, äh, raw machen. So, und
das erste, was man machen muss, also
im Prinzip besteht das unter Windows, eine Festplatte zu formatieren
besteht unter Windows aus vier oder fünf Schritten. Das erste ist,
man muss die Festplatte initialisieren.
Ich weiß nicht, was Microsoft darunter versteht, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Keine Ahnung. Aber man muss es machen. Man sieht hier nämlich auch, das Ding hier hat so einen Pfeil
nach unten. Und nachdem es initialisiert ist, wie gesagt,
was auch immer das genau heißt, ähm, dann
freut sich Windows. Dann ist es initialisiert. Danach muss es
partitionieren. Nachdem es partitioniert hast, musst du es formatieren.
Und wenn es formatiert hast, dann kannst du dem neuen Volumen
einen Laufwerksbuchstabe zuordnen. Also, unter
Windows muss man das folgendermaßen machen. Zuerst DiskInit.
Danach muss man, ähm, partitionieren. Danach muss man
formatieren. Danach muss man mappen.
So funktioniert das unter Windows.
Also im Prinzip das, was du unter Linux mit einer Zeile machst. Aber das, so ist das halt.
Wir sind ja unter Windows. Das darf man nicht vergessen.
So, ähm, es ist wirklich
übelst Exploding Brain, ja, also was man dafür machen muss.
So funktioniert das auch. Ich würde sagen, wir machen uns jetzt erstmal eine Methode,
wo man eine Festplatte wieder löschen kann.
Wobei, nee, das bringt ja nichts. Die ist ja schon leer. Da weiß ich ja gar nicht, ob es funktioniert.
Alter, kannst du mal dieses... Warte mal.
So, Exclusive Mode. Da kann ich jetzt hier oben rum
vorwerken, wie ich lustig bin. Okay, also ich würde sagen, wir brauchen mal
für unseren Disk Format, da brauchen wir eine Public
Methode, die wir nennen Format All Disks.
Das ist so simpel von der ARP her, das kann jeder aufrufen. Format All Disks.
So, und nun müssen wir, und das habe ich mir im Vorfeld schon rausgesucht,
jetzt müssen wir folgendes machen. Ähm,
ich glaube, das hier ist das Richtige.
Copy Paste. So, jetzt muss man folgendes machen, und zwar ich erkläre das gleich, was
das Zeug, was das Zeug...
Warum kann ich das hier nicht inkluden? Warum macht mein Wishlist Studio das nicht?
Warum muss ich das von Hand machen? Was soll das?
System... Was brauchen wir? System Management.
System... Wo ist es denn?
System Management brauchen wir. Da ist der ganze Schmodder hier drin.
What? Nein, nein, nein.
Using.
Okay. Ähm, so.
Und was das hier jetzt macht, ist, das sagt,
ich möchte, also dieses System
Management ist diese... Wie heißt das?
Windows Management Infrastructure Management...
Nee.
Wie heißt das? Was heißt WMI?
Windows, Windows, Zeugs.
Windows Management Instrumental...
Was?
Windows Management Instrumentation.
Ah. Jetzt sind wir gleich viel schlauer.
Jetzt ist quasi komplett am
explodieren, ja.
Easy. Absolut. Eats as fuck.
So. Und, ähm...
Wozu
brauchst du ein Programm, das dir die Disk formatiert?
Dafür liefert Windows doch eine schicke UI mit.
Das hab ich doch bevor ich angefangen... Da warst du auch schon da. Das hab ich bevor ich angefangen, hab doch 20 Minuten lang erklärt.
Das ist nicht für mich. Das ist
ihr Management Tool für Hardware-Adrinne, wo sie ihre frisch
aufgebauten Rechner aktivieren können und Festplatten formatieren.
Ah, ich zeig's dir nochmal.
Du hast hier das Management Interface.
Du hast hier das Web Interface,
wo du deine ganzen Windows Keys drinne hast. Hier siehst du, wann Rechner
aktiviert wurden. Und dafür gibt's da noch einen kleinen Programm,
das hier, was die Windows-Aktivierung macht und Mac-Adresse
und sowas übermittelt. So. Und dieses kleine Program soll jetzt
nicht nur Windows aktivieren können, sondern auch Festplatten formatieren können.
Und das muss natürlich
automatisch funktionieren.
Moment. Crap.
Ihr hört mich noch, wenn ich die VM auf Fullscreen mach, oder?
Hört ihr mich noch?
Weil nicht, dass ich die VM...
dass ich die VM jetzt irgendwie in meine Soundkarte gekrappt hat oder sowas.
Ist der Klein Poggers oder Coggers?
Der Server ist Proggers und der Klein ist Coggers, weil ich
gedacht hab, das ist eine gute Idee, das Zeug so zu nennen.
Jo. Ich find das übrigens nice, dass wieder 120 Leute
gestartet sind um 19.50 Uhr am Dienstag.
Obwohl ich jetzt schon wieder eineinhalb Wochen kaum gestreamt hab. Oder ne, eine Woche ist es
ungefähr her, oder? Also ich hab jetzt ja nicht mehr so viel gestreamt
letzte Woche wie die Woche davor. Aber jetzt hab ich Urlaub, jetzt werde ich wahrscheinlich
jeden Tag oder jeden zweiten Tag wieder streamen sollen.
So. Genau. Und mit
dieser, wir haben es gerade gelernt, mittels Windows-Management
Instrumentation können wir jetzt sagen, okay,
wir wollen alle Festplatten, die in dem
jeweiligen Rechner drin sind, wollen wir abfragen.
Dazu muss man sagen, wir möchten quasi innerhalb von WMI
diese Microsoft Windows Storage
Management API Classes verwenden.
Windows Storage Management API wollen wir verwenden über WMI.
Ich hoffe, das ist Windows Technik so korrekt, wie ich das so sag. So, und das kann man
alle, jetzt können wir hier alle Disks abfragen. So. Und ich zeig euch mal,
dass wir auch wirklich alle Disks abfragen können damit.
Man kann jetzt hier zum Beispiel sagen,
er möge starten, bitte.
Achso, vielleicht soll ich
vielleicht soll ich erstmal, vielleicht soll ich nochmal sagen, wir wollen
warten, nicht einfach beenden.
Und vor allem sollte ich erst nochmal sagen, New Disk Formatter,
soll ich das Ding erstmal anlegen.
So, jetzt
aber. So.
Das sind meine beiden Disks, die ich drinne hab.
Geschwubbel 1, Geschwubbel 2 hier, VmW Disks.
Und Desktop Rinskfk68Q.
Random Name.
Also, wie man sieht, ich hab jetzt wirklich die beiden Festplatten abgefragt, wie man auch hier drinne
sieht, bezieht sich das nur auf Disks, also auf
keine CD-Laufwerke, die sind da nicht drinne, halt richtige Disks oder SSDs.
Und,
ja, so kann ich das Ganze abfragen.
Als nächstes, und das hab ich im Vorfall auch schon nachgeguckt,
als nächstes gibt es jetzt, wenn man sich jetzt hier mal anguckt, bei Microsoft,
in diese MSFT Disk Class
kann man wiederum selbst, ich hab keine Ahnung, welches Hirn sich das
bei Microsoft ausgedacht hat, das ist wirklich übermäßig
kompliziert.
Welches Keytool mach mal, Ausrufezeichen
R-Tool, ja genau, der Clocks hat schon gemacht.
Da erklär ich das. Und das Tool ist an sich ja eigentlich
so weit funktionsfähig, aber wie das halt so ist, sobald
das quasi verwendet wird, stellt man natürlich fest, was man sonst noch so
alles einbauen könnte, und es gibt noch einige Sachen.
Heute machen wir das mit Festplattenformatieren ein. So, und
man kann jetzt wiederum, nachdem man jetzt alle, das soll sich mal verpissen hier
oben, das komische, verämmert Gedönster, nachdem wir jetzt ja
alle Disks abgefragt haben, an dieser Stelle kann man jetzt
wiederum auf diesem abgefragten WMI-Objekt
kann man selbst wiederum Sachen aufrufen, weil
sich Microsoft gedacht hat, das ist eine tolle Idee, das so zu machen, und
diese MSFT Disk Class
aus der Windows Storage Management API, die wir über die
Windows Management Instrumentation abgefragt haben,
also dreht sich echt dem Kopf alles rum, weil wir alle schon beim Aussprechen,
darüber gibt es wieder eine Methode, die sich Initialize nennt.
Und die können wir jetzt aufrufen. Und zwar, das kann man folgendermaßen
aufrufen. Man kann jetzt hier nämlich sagen, okay,
ach so, wir sollten uns jetzt vielleicht mal rausholen,
dass wir nur die Disk formatieren, die
leer ist. Meine Systemplatte muss ich nicht unbedingt formatieren.
Wisst ihr was? Heute
kein Bock auf YOLO-Programming, wir machen mal
nen Snapshot. Wir machen mal nen Snapshot vorn auf VM,
falls ich meine Systemplatte lösche. Dass ich Windows nicht neu installieren muss, muss nicht sein.
So,
und folgende Sachen
kann ich jetzt quasi von jedem, wie gesagt, ich frage hier alle
MSFT Disk Objekte ab,
und diese Sachen werden mir da angeboten. Unter anderem gibt es da
so was hier wie
ähm...
Wo ist es denn hier? Es gab doch hier irgendwie so was wie
ID oder sowas. Unique ID?
War das Unique ID? Wir müssen zumindest die
richtige Festplatte erwischen.
War das Unique ID? An der Stelle, ja, das
könnte es gewesen sein. An der Stelle übrigens mal
der Hinweis, das würde ich immer in der VM machen. Also falls ihr auch
irgendwelche Sachen mit, wir formatieren Festplatten oder so,
mal basteln wollt, macht das in der VM, sonst kann es sein,
dass ihr euer System schrottet. Normalerweise eigentlich nicht,
weil man keine Rechte hat mit seinem normalen User, das zu formatieren,
aber es reicht ja auch schon, wenn man aus Versehen einen USB-Stick formatiert, den man nicht formatieren will.
Das muss ja nicht unbedingt sein.
Hey Max, hast du eigentlich einen Community-Squad oder sowas geplant?
Hier sowas ist schon ewig geplant.
Ja, ja.
Leider, leider schon ewig geplant.
So, und zwar
was das Ganze hier noch anbietet, ist ein
da ist es, Partition Style.
Das heißt, ich kann mir jetzt anzeigen lassen, von jeder Festplatte
in meiner VM oder meinem Rechner, den Partition
Style. So, die erste Festplatte hat Partition Style 2,
die zweite Festplatte hat Partition Style 0. Und dann kann man wiederum hier
nachgucken, das eins muss man ja Microsoft zugute halten, die
schreiben den Scheiß wenigstens auf. Es ist zwar unglaublich konfus, das ganze Zeug hier,
aber es steht wenigstens überall was da. So, und man kann hier nämlich nachgucken,
der Partition Style,
oder auch nicht,
zumindest
ist Partition Style 0 nicht initialisiert.
Das habe ich schon rausgekriegt. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, wo es
stand, ehrlich gesagt.
Ach, da steht es, genau.
Also, Partition Style bedeutet 0,
Partition Style unknown. Partition Style 1 ist MBR
und Partition Style 2 ist GPT, also das Neue.
Was steht in GPT nochmal?
Global? Nee.
Was steht in GPT?
Ah, ah, GUID, Partition Table.
Ah ja. Das Zeug, ich frage mich immer,
wer sich das alles immer ausfällt, wenn ich merken kann diese Abkürzung. Ich gucke immer
einfach nach.
Was steht daneben?
Ah ja, steht daneben. Lul.
Siehst du mal, es ist genau wie ich gesagt habe, Microsoft schreibt
ihren Krempel wenigstens auf. Ob ich dann sehe, ist was anderes, aber
Microsoft schreibt den Krempel wenigstens auf. Oh, geh weg, VMWR.
Piss dich, Alde. Don't show again.
So, Partition Style, das heißt, wir können jetzt ein bisschen Link-Matching machen, wir können sagen
Where, Partition Style
gleich 0.
Falscher Typ.
Where, Partition Style,
String, das geht bestimmt schöner, aber mal gucken.
Where.
Ah. Okay.
Okay, und jetzt kriege ich nur noch die Disks
mit Partition Style unbekannt, was bedeutet, noch nicht
initialisiert oder sonst was. So, dann nennen wir das Ding mal Disk.
Disk. So, und jetzt können wir sagen
Disk Invoke Method
Clear, das brauchen wir auch noch gleich, dann können wir den Kram wieder löschen, den wir da so fabrizieren
und Initialize.
Und Initialize bekommt
übergeben ein Parameter, wo man sagen
kann, 1 für MBR und 2 für GPT.
Also, können wir jetzt sagen, wie schreibt man das?
Initialize
und dann will er nicht. Warum will er nicht?
Ah, weil ich den Parameter übergeben muss.
Wie geht denn das?
Wir übergeben mal einfach 0
und gucken, was passiert. Vielleicht ist der GPT schon Standard
und wir müssen gar nichts machen. Okay, also
von der Idee her sollte jetzt diese Platte danach
Initialisiert sein.
Sie ist Initialisiert. Poggers, Alter.
Poggers. Festplatte Initialisiert. Ist zwar noch nichts partitioniert oder sonst was.
Okay, und jetzt brauchen wir noch eine zweite Methode, dass wir ordentlich testen können.
Clear Disk
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal gefragt habe, aber wie stehst du zum Programmieren auf dem Zettel
bei Klausuren? Programmieren auf Zettel ist in der heutigen Zeit für
absolute Basics vielleicht noch okay, aber eigentlich ist es bescheuert
Programmieren auf Zettel. Wir sind nicht mal 1990 oder so.
Man sollte den Leuten auch ordentliche Werkzeuge
geben. Man muss es heute nicht auswendig können.
Ohne Scheiß. Ich weiß auch die meisten Sachen nicht auswendig. Ich weiß ungefähr
Dafür ist es auch mittlerweile viel zu vielfältig alles. Ich weiß ungefähr
was man braucht. Dann wird Google angeschmissen, einfach geguckt. Okay, wie hieß
der Kram jetzt genau? Und dann hat man es. Man muss den ganzen Kram
immer auswendig können.
C Prüfung auf dem Zettel auch noch C.
Also quasi eines der Programme, die wirklich noch am meisten von einer
ordentlichen Entwicklungsumgebung profitieren. Dann auch noch C.
Wir brauchen also was wie Clear Disk brauchen wir, weil
wir müssen jetzt ja quasi vor jedem Durchlauf die
Festplatte wieder löschen, weil wir sonst nicht wissen,
dass unser Zeug funktioniert. Das ist natürlich irgendwo klar, oder?
Okay.
Nachdem wir wahrscheinlich diese
Disk, dieses Disk getten hier, noch sau
oft brauchen werden, machen wir mal eine eigene Methode draus.
Ne, kein Problem. Irgendetwas wie
private
Disks oder können wir Property draus machen. Get Disks
und dann kriegen wir da zurück ein Management
ein Enumerable of Management Object
kriegen wir zurück.
Zack, zack, zack,
zack. Get Disks.
Ja, so und jetzt kann ich hier nämlich auch schon sagen.
Get Disks.
Äh, was hatte für Schmerzen?
Hä? Ah!
Da, steht sogar da.
Genau, das werden wir wahrscheinlich öfters brauchen und jetzt
können wir das eigentlich in ein Property umwandeln lassen.
Das finde ich halt in Visual Studio auch ganz praktisch. Da muss man den Scheiß, das nervige Zeug
oftmals halt nicht mehr von Hand machen. So, guck. Und jetzt
kriege ich jedes Mal, wenn ich Disks aufrufe
aktuelle Collection mit
Festplatten und was die für einen Status
haben. So, jetzt kommen wir hier Initialize. So, jetzt brauchen wir die nächste
Sache, die wir aufrufen, ist Clear Disk.
Ich mache jetzt immer als erstes Clear Disk, weil wir wollen ja testen und wir können
nicht testen, wenn die Festplatte jedes Mal voll ist. Also Clear Disk. So, Clear Disk
ruft man folgendermaßen auf, wir brauchen wieder
Warum mache ich eigentlich sowas hier? Ist doch total beknackt.
Ah, ich habe eine Idee. Wir machen Clear Disk
Nummer
und dann sagen wir, das ist Disk
Where
Disk, es gab hier irgendwie
eine Nummer von der Festplatte, die wir hier
verwendet haben. Also, hier
irgendwie eine Nummer von der Platte konnte man sich
ausgeben lassen. Number of Partitions
Es gab hier irgendwie
so eine eindeutige, ne, Unique ID meine ich nicht.
Number
Gab es hier doch irgendwo.
Number, einfach nur Number.
Geh weg!
So, Number gleich
dem, den ich übergebe und ich weiß in dem Fall, dass ich die erste will.
Ich will immer die erste. Das schreibe ich dann hier unten rein.
Disk One,
weil die erste ist meine Systemplatte, die zweite, also die erste, hier mit eins
geht ja ab Null los.
Äh
Was hat der eigentlich für Schmerzen hier mit?
Ah, weil das ein Int ist und das hier
ist ein, das ist kein String
Das ist ein, was ist denn das überhaupt? Ein Management Object
Gut, ich meine
ich könnte sowas machen, aber das ist ja nur wirklich, das ist natürlich nur wirklich nicht
schön, ne?
Wartet mal, ich hab ne Idee, wir gucken mal, was das hier
ist. Wir gucken, wir gucken mal, was das hier ist.
Konsol, Debugging
Ach so, ähm
Ach scheiße, da war mal doch nicht Konsol, Debugging
Da war mal doch Debugger
Debugger
Gucken, was da drinne steht
Hallo, Debugger, kannst du mir was anzeigen?
Ah ne, der hat das noch gar nicht ausgeführt. Ok, Disks, was ist
denn in Disks drinne?
Das sieht man jetzt nicht richtig, ne? Das ist natürlich kacke
Krieg ich jetzt raus, was da drinne ist?
Ne, egal, machen wir es doch so
Äh, Disks,
Firsts oder Lasts, weil wir wollen ja die zweite Disks
Last, Number, und dann gucken wir mal, was da drinne ist, wahrscheinlich ein Int oder sowas
Ah ja, ein Unsigned Int ist da drinne
Da können wir jetzt nämlich ein schönes neues C Sharp, glaube 6 oder 7 Feature verwenden
Ähm, wir können nämlich sagen
Wenn
das da ein Unsigned Intager ist
Value und Value ist
Ähm, gleich der Nummer, die wir übergeben
haben
Ja, genau, wir nehmen den ersten Eintrag
Wo die Nummer gleich der übrigen
Nummer ist, also in dem Fall hier 1
Das ist ein richtig nice C Sharp, ich glaube 6 Feature ist das
Man kann das jetzt quasi in einem Statement machen, man kann jetzt quasi den Typ überprüfen
und im gleichen Statement gucken, ob der Typ, wenn das denn
von diesem Typ ist, ob es denn, ja, irgendwie in der anderen Vergleich halt
zutrifft. So, jetzt können wir sagen, Disk, Invoke
und jetzt einfach sagen, Clear
So, und jetzt sollte von der Idee her eigentlich die Festplatte wieder
äh, ja, entinitialisiert werden
Oh, es hängt. Hängen ist schlecht
Aber es ist wieder entinitialisiert. Krasser Scheiß. Okay, funktioniert
Das heißt, wir können jetzt immer sagen Format Disk
Also, wir können jetzt immer sagen Clear Disk oder Format All Disks
Und wir gucken wir bei der ganzen Sache mal zu, wir sagen hier übrigens noch mal so eine Sache vorher
Exit, so, dass wir wissen, dass wir fertig sind
Nicht zugeordnet, okay
Wir können jetzt mal starten
Genau, äh, erlöscht es wieder
Und danach initialisiert. Das ist okay, das funktioniert gut
Heißt, entinitialisieren, unmountet, pff, weiß nicht
Das heißt, ja, das heißt, clear, du clearst
Was, was macht er denn?
Removes Partition Information, ne, ne, ne, ne, Moment
Clear? Clear, ja, machen wir
Erlöscht Partition Information und
Uninitialisiert Disk
Also, wahrscheinlich, wenn er auch die Partitionsinformation
Ähm
Erlöscht wird es wahrscheinlich auch unmounten, ja
Und er stellt es hier irgendwie wieder auf, auf
Down oder so
Okay, was haben wir denn hier für, was haben wir denn hier für Parameter zu übergeben
In, remove data, true
Ja, ja, ja, das sollte man vielleicht machen, oder
Äh, true, if, if it's false or null, fail
Remove data, remove OEM
Nö, das brauchen wir nicht
Zero out entire disk, brauchen wir auch nicht
Okay, wie, ach guck mal, der Kawaii Shox hat gerade
Geschrieben, wie das funktioniert
Okay, Parameter
Parameter, clear, also
Schauen wir mal an, was das für Optionen gibt
Mit hohen Name, also, mein, allein schon, ganz ehrlich, Microsoft, ja
Wenn die sowas anbieten, warum nicht in irgendeiner typisierten Variante, das muss ich hier mit komischen
Stringgedönse rumbasteln, ey
Da gibt's doch mittlerweile schönere Varianten, das ist doch echt ähnlich, ey, eklig, ey
Das ist wirklich eklig, das Zeug hier
Okay, clear, ähm
Object Array, willkommen im Jahr 2018
Object Array, äh, Moment, was gibt's denn sonst noch so
Für Sachen, warte mal, äh, Object Array
Ein Management Operation Observer
Was auch immer
Management Base Object in Parameters
Okay, das sieht, das hört sich ein bisschen typisierter an und irgendwelche
Invoke Method Options, aha, und das Ganze nochmal
Mit einem Management Operation Observer
Microsoft, please, was, was ist denn da, was, was passiert da überhaupt
Ist halt
Low Level API, ja, deswegen muss man sie trotzdem nicht eklig zu benutzen machen
Ja, Patrick, da hast du recht, Management
Operation Observer könnte, könnte, äh, glatt, glatt aus Java kommen
Wobei in Java würde das Ding wahrscheinlich Management
Operation Observer Factory Singleton heißen
Das wäre der passende Java Name davon, okay, also was
New Object Array und dann müssen wir Parameter
übergeben, über, übergebt man die der Reihenfolge nach
Wahrscheinlich, ne, also ich würde davon ausgehen
Normalerweise übergebt man Parameter der Reihenfolge nach, sowas wie es da steht, aber
Ich bin mir nachher bei Microsoft mittlerweile nicht mehr sicher, ne
Remove Data, also machen wir jetzt sowas hier wie Remove Data True
Danach sagen wir Remove OEM Fall, das ist doch nicht
den hier ernst, oder, ähm, Zero Out Entire Disk
Fall, Alter, ist das hässlich, was ist denn das hier
In, das ist ja, das sieht ja aus wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend
Äh, also das fängt schon mal, Patrick Scheiße
ist das, das ist ja Massive hässlich, ey
Erste Mal fängt schon mal an mit, dass man die Methode nicht direkt aufrufen
kann, weil es ne Klasse dafür gibt, mein, so viel ist das nicht, ja, gibt ein paar Klassen
Aber es ist nicht so, dass 3 Milliarden werden, sondern, keine Ahnung, 30 oder so, man hätte es
einfach, man hätte es einfach, ne,
Warte mal, gibt es denn Github, Github, MSFT
Rapper
Das gibt's doch, hat auch bestimmt
Das hat auch bestimmt schon irgendjemand für uns gebaut
Aha
Was such mal nach
Disk Utils
Nein, wir wollen das nicht übersetzen
Ja, das ist schön
Das ist gut, da muss man die Scheiße nicht übersetzen
Nice, sehr, sehr nice, ASMR Stream
Setup Transporter, Setup Files, Setup Complete
Wir machen das jetzt aber mal selbst
Einfach, dass man rausklickt, wie das funktioniert
10++
Examples, haut ab